ça va ça va très bien
recyclées
et c'est 112 heures de travail dans les
ah c'est qui ça je me disais
c'est plus de 250 bouteilles d'eau et
viande aussi les copains
le petit au polo rouge
ah oui je le vois ah oui il est mignon
oh ouais t'as du goût
mais alors je comprends pas tu me dis
qu'il ressemblait à Johnny Depp ouais
les oreilles de Johnny Depp ah ouais
ouais c'est vrai qu'il y a un petit truc
au niveau du lobe qui ressemble à quoi
c'est laquelle qui lui tourne autour à
Pablo la petite Luna tu m'en as parlé là
pull violet alors attends
salut tout le monde c'est Louise Attaque
on espère que vous allez bien on est
dans un petit jardin je sais pas si vous
voyez il y a des tomates tout ça et on
voulait vous dire que notre nouveau
single sortir de l'ordinaire est présent
et là sur toutes les plateformes on
compte sur vous allez du coup
Grand Corps Malade un artiste simple en
effet il a su rester proche de ses fans
proche de la Seine
[Musique]